à
bonsoir à tous merci d'être avec nous
dentiste à mon poste c'est soir on
voulait absolument démarrer cette
émission par une minute de silence
suite au drame qui s'est passé vendredi
dernier puisque samuel pâti au fait
soeur d'histoire géographie dans un
collège des yvelines a été sauvagement
assassiné par un terroriste notre
émission est énorme armand regardé par
par les jeunes par par les enseignants
et ce soir voilà on a tous bien sûr une
pensée pour tous les enseignants pour la
famille de monsieur paty et on a tous
passé un week end on s'est dit on veut
pas de ce monde là c'est pas un monde
dans lequel on a envie de vivre et c'est
vrai qu'en ce moment il se passe des
choses très très pesant pour tout le
monde et c'est vrai que voilà on s'est
dit c'est cesser c'est pas que ce monde
là qu'on veut on aimerait alors c'est
bête que je vais dire ccc et vous on
aimerait un monde d'amour c'est beaucoup
plus simple d'être dans un monde d'amour
qu'un monde de haine et j'ai ce qu'on
aimerait voir aujourd'hui sur tout et
tout ce qui se passe faut vraiment qu'on
soit tous soudés je vous dis c'est un
message aussi que j'ai laissées sur les
réseaux sociaux ce week-end c'est vrai
qu'on a besoin d'être tous ensemble face
à l'adversité face à tout ce qui se
passe où on le voit et ce qui s'est
passé vendredi à tous ça nous a fait
passer et nous ça nous a fait passer un
week-end dégueulasse on va pas se mentir
parce qu'on a tous pensé vous pouvez pas
s'amuser comme on voulait ce week-end ne
pouvait pas même aujourd'hui on doit
tous penser
bien entendu quand on s'est revus et ce
drame qui s'est passé vendredi soir
vendredi dernier il faut plus que ça
arrive ça ça ne peut plus arriver c'est
vraiment voilà tous les jeunes qui nous
regardent tous les enseignants qui nous
regardent
on pense forcément à bout je voulais
vous montrer cette image aussi de ce
jeune qui parle de son professeur qui
nous a extrêmement ému c'est pape
c'est un message un témoignage qui a
marqué les français
il a 12 ans il fait partie du même
collège et ça mais elle pâtit et
regardez ce qu'il dit et c'est vrai
qu'on on a tous aimé nos enseignants aux
éducateurs voilà
on les admirer et il ya énormément
d'élèves qui admiraient sa meule pâtit
regardez ce que dit ce jeune homme on
doit venir se rassembler pour protester
contre cette barbarie et cette violence
c'est bon c'est pas normal
j'ai pleuré parce que c'est c'est très
grave je me dis si maintenant on entre
juste assez les à ses élèves une
caricature bien mal et on devient un
raciste du coup alors on ne peut plus
rien dire du coup d'état n'était pas
possible en fait j'ai vraiment peur
parce que je me dis qu'à tout moment
on peut se faire agresser alors que
alors qu'en fait que c'est c'est pas
censé arriver il faut pas je trouve
qu'il faut pas alors donné ça où tu
mérite pas ça prouve qu'il faut au
contraire continuer encore à apprendre
sinon les terroristes et ils vont gagner
voilà et c'est magnifique ce que nice se
joint debout devant nous et c'est vrai
qu'il faut dialoguer il faut qu'on soit
dans dialogues jouer merci grand corps
malade et frédérique bel d'être avec lui
aujourd'hui avant tout les sujets du
jour
je voulais vraiment vous faire réagir ou
aussi tous les chroniqueurs autour de la
table des invités aussi à ce que ce
vendredi il y aura un avant et un après
ce vendredi dans notre vie à tous fabien
cango malades merci d'être là je trouve
que tu es vraiment voilà on fait plein
de choses là on voit ton dernier album
il ya plein de messages dedans et c'est
vrai qu'on a honte aussi je suis sûr que
tu as plein de messages à faire passer
je suis sûr que ce week-end tu as pensé
qu'à ça comme nous tous ouais bien sûr
là on est arrivé à un niveau d'horreur
rarement égalée enfin c'est difficile de
parler après le petit nation il a tout
dit comme lui j'ai peur maintenant je me
dis et maintenant tout est possible à
tout moment pour un mot pour un geste
pour un acte bas c'était l'acte
d'enseignants qu'artiste maintenant tu
te poses des questions dans ce que tu
écris audi gesner enfin oui c'est bien
sûr je me les pose la question mais je
veux pas que ça devienne 9 juin que ça
m'empêche évidemment moi j'avais écrit
un texte que jusqu'à appeler je suis
chargé dans la nuit qui avait suivi les
attentats de charlie hebdo kids est à
nous tous maintenant de prendre un
pinceau un stylo un micro voilà
justement pour lutter contre
l'obscurantisme et justement pour dire
non ils vont pas gagner niveau un vrai
ils nous font un peu peur mais il faut
pas que ça soit il faut que la liberté
d'expression on continue à la criée à la
levée le bien le point bien haut et a
continué notre métier d'artiste à dire
ce qu'on a envie de dire mais je vais te
dire mais moi j'ai pu dire des trucs
voilà des bêtises parce que par peur
aussi parce que je suis j'ai peur qu'ils
aient des innocents qu'ils soient
touchés charlie hebdo c'était des
innocents les voilà on l'a vu encore
yaya et à cannes ya quelques semaines
les personnes qui étaient en bas du
derrière du local de l'ancien local du
chahid optimisant son n'y a que des
innocents qui sont touchés alors on
commence à avoir peur on se dit voyez
peut-être qu'il faut faire attention
mais en vrai c'est vrai que voilà
c'est une connerie en vrai il faut
continuer à se battre pour la liberté
d'expression et c'est une leçon que
vient de dire ce ce jeune homme de 12
ans frédérique bel
je voulais tout ce que vous réagissiez
je voulais tout à votre façon
ce soir parce que vous avez tous des
sensibilités différentes des parcours
différents des mots différents
j'aimerais que vous vraiment vous
réagissiez ce qui s'est passé vendredi
frédéric ben moi je suis sidéré comme la
plupart des gens je devais être
enseignante à la base et voilà il
applique un il applique un programme qui
leur est imposé par la république on
sanctionne ça ça veut dire que tous les
enseignants pas faire passer ça en fait
aujourd'hui les enseignants je peux vous
dire ils ont le moral au plus bas elles
font un travail exceptionnel dans des
conditions de plus en plus difficile et
on a de moins en moins et c'est vrai que
ce que vous disiez vous vouliez être
enseignant il ya plein de gens quand on
est petit combien il yad'enfants à
l'époque qui disaient je veux devenir
instituteur nous devenir professeur je
vais devenir maîtresse papa way est
aujourd'hui de moins en moins parce que
il voit même la difficulté qu'il ya
enseigné il faut aider des professeurs
il faut les aider parce que on en a
besoin et c'est eux qui vont faire plus
tard comme nos parents ils ont ils ont
une vraiment jolie et ils ont une
importance presque presque aussi
importante que nos parents puisque c'est
eux qui vont faire l'homme où la femme
qu'on va devenir plus tard indications
mais d'aviation sur bages à madame moi
moi mes enfants ils sont ils ont hissé
et ils sont terrorisés maintenant disent
que je peux continuer à dire ce que je
pense du bien évidemment et ce qui
coince kim qui m'angoisse et
qu'effectivement il faut pas qu'on ait
peur même si en assurant mais ce qu'on a
vu là et c'est épouvantable et je vois
mais mais mais deux gamins qui était
plutôt insouciant il ya eu bien sûr les
attentats mais là j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont ils ont pris fin presque pour
eux et pas vraiment étonnant et jordi
n'ayez pas peur et continuer à parler et
c'est vrai que il faut s'exprimer c'est
que c'est ça va ça va être compliqué
pour la rentrée géraldine prix bas c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu d'abord beaucoup de
peine beaucoup d'effroi beaucoup
d'indignation
puis après c'est passé par la colère
aussi star weekend un peu
un peu effectivement compliqué puis
beaucoup de désespoir parce qu'on se dit
que le avant après on l'a déjà émis deux
fois ce débat on a eu la preuve après
charlie après un tacle en exactement
comme vous dites à charbon dit il faut
faire quelque chose il faut qu'on avance
est vraiment là il faut vraiment que le
gouvernement et les gens qui sont en
charge de deux voilà de nous on va dire
parce qu'on est un petit peu voilà il
faut vraiment qu'ils fassent quelque
chose parce que là ça a traumatisé
énormément de gens et l'école éducation
un enseignant c'est c'est vraiment c'est
un signe et c'est un symbole très
important pour les ballons le voir
garder les enfants de baja membres dans
tout le monde a été touché par ce qui
s'est passé et un désespoir parce
qu'effectivement avec mes trois ados à
la maison moi j'ai regardé les gens qui
écoutaient sur les réseaux sociaux
et je dois dire ça a été un vide abyssal
c'est à dire que à part omar sy à part
peut-être hakim djemilli j'ai pas
entendu un rappeur en parler j'ai pas
entendu un sportif de haut niveau en
parler j'ai entendu quelques acteurs
mais j'ai pas entendu les influenceurs
en parler j'ai pas entendu les jeux
c'est pas les gens sur youtube en parler
et ça m'a fait du mal parce que c'est
eux
en fait qu'ils écoutent aujourd'hui
alors vous vous êtes effectivement
prescripteurs pour la jeunesse dont ça
c'est bien là ce que vous avez toujours
tout de suite pris la parole mais j'ai
trouvé qu'ils avaient quand même un
grand vide alors que par ailleurs c'est
des gens qui montent au créneau pour des
très belles causes qu'on rogne dont on
parle et pour autant voilà et mal
et aujourd'hui il ya eu un peu d'espoir
pour moi j'ai entendu l'imam de drancy
on en parlait crawl à l'heure avec jeu
avec benjamin qui a été exceptionnel
un homme des lumières un homme de la
paix et voilà et donc il ya de l'espoir
malgré tout dans le désespoir
jean mi bah oui c'est un week end assez
horrible j'avoue ça m'a moi ça m'a
ramené personnellement une vingtaine
d'années en arrière à l'époque où je
faisais un métier où j'étais habitué à
aller tous les mois dans les pays où la
guerre civile ces constats reporter de
guerre et où l'horreur la barbarie ne ne
choquait presque même plus dans la rue
on voyait des corps démembré des corps
qui étaient mutilés et caetera et ça ne
choquait même plus donc je pense que
content qu'on chope encore comme ça que
j'espère qu'on arrivera pas s'habituer à
ce genre de vision parce que franchement
c'est tellement ans j'ai eu le malheur
de recevoir par un kaka cul ça
m'intéresserait de m'envoyer la photo
qui avait posté le terroriste on voit le
la tête
de ce professeur et j'ai vu un tel choc
quand j'ai vu la photo que je me dis que
j'espère que déjà plus jamais on verra
j'en ai photos etc on s'habituera jamais
à ce genre de choses c'est que c'est
chaud je pense surtout aux enfants aux
enfants aux élèves de ce professeur qui
vous retournerons en quinze jours à
l'école qui le verront plus et qui ne
pourront pas j'imagine pense à autre
chose qui à ce professeur et l'imaginent
décapité torture etc
et je pense à eux surtout parce que pour
nous on est adulte et sert à nous pour
les enfants grandir se construire dans
un tel choc
ça va être terrible pour eux ça
maintenant et moi j'ai du mal à trouver
les mots parce que je pense que je
reviens à ce que disent les gens mais je
ne m'habituerai jamais à tant de temps
d'horreur temps de d'atrocités et comme
fondu le week-end gâché et j'ai eu et
j'ai peur c'est vrai que ça fait peur il
ya un avant et un après cette affaire un
comment ça y est j'ai peur qu'on sait
qu'on s'habitue et je ne veux vraiment
pas qu'on s'habitue à sa merci
gilles c'est bouleversant c'est
bouleversé parce que d'abord en pensant
à cet enseignant mais à tous les
enseignants qui sont auteurs du message
républicain sans les enseignants il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas de communication il n'y
a pas de citoyenneté pour nos enfants
ce sont eux qui vont faire que nos
enfants vont connaître et apprendre les
valeurs de la république
donc il faut que les enseignants soient
soutenus protégé pour qu'ils puissent
enseigner en toute liberté
et aussi je voudrais penser parce que ça
me touche particulièrement à tous les
musulmans qui aujourd'hui sont
malheureux parce que l'islam c'est pas
ça islam c'est une région une religion
de paix de partage c'est pas des
musulmans c'est des terroristes et tous
les musulmans aujourd'hui comme nous
tous sont bouleversés de voir que leur
religion peut être dévoyé bien dîné à ce
point là je voulais qu'on en parle ce
soir en début d'émission
bien sûr parce que je vous ai promis
aussi ça sur twitter on avait vraiment
vous divertir soit parce que je sais que
vous en avez besoin
est ce qu'on ferme et je voulais
vraiment qu'on démarre l'émission en
parlant de ça parce qu'on est des
missions peut-être l'émission la plus
regardée par les plus jeunes
voilà c'est vrai que de regarder en
famille il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
jeunes qui nous regardent et beaucoup de
deux des led qui sont voilà qui peut
être pas envie d'en parler et nous voir
en parler avec eux ce soir
c'est aussi peut-être ça peut voilà ça
peut aussi à leur faire du bien parce
que voilà on pourra jamais revenir en
arrière et c'est un drame mais voilà ils
vont peut-être se sentir avec nous aussi
l'envi de pouvoir y changer vous pouvez
échanger avec nous sur les réseaux
sociaux
et comme si on en parle avec vous il
avait un moi j'ai été très vite dans le
combat tout cas un temps pour les
marchés un temps pour les fleurs et un
temps pour se battre contre
effectivement cette horreur pour tous
les nuances et pour tous les modérés du
monde entier qu'ils soient juifs qu'ils
ont quasiment qu'ils soient catholiques
et donc je trouve que c'est vraiment
très très important parce que c'est pas
seul champ libre dos qui est concerné
c'est tout l'enseignement
tout le monde m'a enseigné l'histoire
comment va c'est la littérature on se
bute constamment à des références que
eux refusent et que les directeurs
d'école que les enseignants veulent
continuer à pouvoir enseigner temps que
moi jetons qu'il est temps que se battre
rêvons alors tu parlais de deux parcours
différents et c'est vrai que moi il ya
un truc que je regrette dans toute ma
vie j'ai fait plein de trucs dans ma vie
j'ai fait des conneries je fus truc bien
un truc pas bien le truc pas bien que
j'ai faite c'est que j'ai arrêté l'école
à 14 ans et le peu que les professeurs
m'ont appris ils me l'ont appris parce
que moi je trouve que c'est important
d'avoir deux versions la version que tu
vas avoir chez toi et la version qu'on
va te donner à l'école alors le au delà
de la digue ou encore malade c'est
horrible au delà du crime c'est une
décapitation le geste l'acte est
horrible et on ne veut pas de ça on ne
veut pas de ça on veut pas entendre
parler de ça parce que ce mec là c'est
pas comme si on entendait une histoire
dit il est dans un trafic de drogue et
aux caisses
son tort ce mec là c'est de vouloir
avoir voulu enseigner le tort qu'il a
c'est qu'il sait lever le matin pour
nous donner du savoir à nous à nous qui
avons pas beaucoup de choses quand on
rentre chez nous que nos parents peuvent
pas nous nous apprendre des choses et
nous éduque nos parents mais peuvent pas
nous apprendre des choses les
professeurs ils sont là pour nous
apprendre des choses les codes de la
république est là pour nous donner une
deuxième version
et moi j'ai eu mal quand au delà du
geste je me suis dit comment c'est
possible mais c'est quoi son tort qu'est
ce qu'il a fait de mal ce mec là
aujourd'hui est plus là il est mort il
est mort pourquoi il est mort il est
mort passage ici est levé un matin pour
un programme scolaire
c'était dans l'actualité parce qu'il y
avait les caricatures de charlie hebdo
qui est en procès il y avait un mec qui
s'était trompé d'endroit et on avait
arrêté un mec qui voulait attaquer
charlie hebdo à la fausse adresse
voilà il a parlé de l'actualité parce
que le programme scolaire doit s'adapter
aussi à la pta l'actualité et moi j'ai
eu mal et j'ai entendu je vais finir sur
gilles très mal jean
tendu que potentiellement il ya des gens
qui pensaient rebaptisé le collège à
conflans comme le collège samuel bâti
allez-y les mecs on a peur de quoi
monsieur monsieur macron monsieur
monsieur blanc caire monsieur castex on
a peur de quoi il la dit quand corps
malade quelque part et nous font peur
mais on va pas leur montrez vous pouvez
rebaptiser ce collège monsieur samuel
pâtit que les enfants aillent à l'école
tous les matins et qu'on leur dise tu as
quel collège toi je suis apathie ckoi
pas ti pas ti c'est un mec qui sied mort
pour la république est mort pour la
laïcité voilà ce que c'est pratique
évidemment extrêmement choqué et
extrêmement peiné à la fois pour la
famille pour cet homme qui s'est battu
pour la liberté pour la liberté
d'expression c'est indispensable c'est
sur les valeurs républicaines
c'est très bien ce que tu as dit moi je
trouve que je trouve ça terrible ce qui
est arrivé mais ce que voulait dire
surtout c'est que maintenant il ya une
récupération qui est fait derrière par
certains politiques ça c'est assez
lamentable parce que ce que je crois qui
est surtout c'est que effectivement
comme le disait gilles faut pas faire
d'amalgamé il ya les musulmans et puis
il ya les salafistes il ya les
extrémistes et c'est cela qu'il faut
combattre il faut pas se tromper de
combat
là il ya un véritable problème auquel je
crois enfin ils vont s'attaquer et on va
essayer peut-être d'essayer d'arrêter
tous ceux de ces horreurs préfère qu'on
reste pour l'instant dans l'émotion
avant de parler de récupération
politique ou d'autres choses franchement
ça on s'en fout totalement de leur
histoire vraiment on s'en tape total y
aura toujours des abrutis pour récupérer
après des drames
voilà des électeurs et ça c'est ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans
la merde dans laquelle on est